bombardeada con quejas sobre los
comentarios xenófobos que alexéi navalni
hizo en el pasado
amnistía internacional decidió quitarle
el estatus de preso de consciencia al
crítico del kremlin de acuerdo con la
organización la designación se da a
aquellos que han sido injustamente
encarcelados por quien son o por lo que
defienden y que no han fomentado la
violencia ni los discursos de odio a
pesar de la revocatoria del estatus
amnistía remarcó que seguirá luchando
por la puesta en libertad de naval negro
2 min
eso no significa que vayamos a cambiar
vamos a tener la misma determinación en
nuestra campaña en nuestro trabajo de
defensa para que sea puesto en libertad
de la prisión esto es una decisión
interna para ser coherentes con nuestra
propia definición de preso de
consciencia
el prisionero con jeans las quejas hacen
referencia a comentarios que naval ni
hizo quince años atrás junto a un vídeo
en el que llega a comparar a los
migrantes con cucarachas naval ni nunca
repitió este tipo de alegaciones pero
tampoco las desmintió y al principio
amnistía las descartó por no considerar
las relevantes en su situación de per se
en política actual los seguidores de
navalny creen que amnistía internacional
ha sido engañada por una campaña de
boicot pro kremlin orquestada para
desacreditar al opositor tras perder una
apelación el sábado el crítico del
kremlin sigue en prisión y sostiene que
su encarcelamiento responde a motivos
políticos
mientras el presidente ruso advirtió
este miércoles sobre los intentos
internacionales de desestabilizar el
país